Mày bây giờ chúng ta đang cây xanh bài tần xanh nhất năm giọng.
Mày bài ra đây.
Không cần học phi công chuyên nghiệp,
giờ đây bàn bận có thể thử cảm chát lái mới bài như hợt.
Có là đặt quân phút dần,
thành phố hồi tri bên quán cập phy này đang tù hút dù bán chẽ,
giờ bố hình trả nhiệm lấy mới bài bố phẩm.
Bố lái được thích kết thường mới bài ở bất à ba hay mươi,
đồng khoảng buổi lập biết buồn.
Nên được tính biết hợi lập xíc không,
mới bước vào kinh bùng lái,
đưa vào không nghĩ lẽ có nhiều lúc như hết.
Thích nhất là khúc mình cất cắn bài,
vài mình thấy hả cắn,
anh có hơi khó hình lúc cắn nè.
Mày bài trả nhiệm,
chính bài từ 2 lợi đến tần xanh nhất,
với vài trò, cơ chưởng.
Trần thường nhất trong cái bộng này,
với cầm ghê, trong trả nhiệm này,
với biết hợt từ nước mọt.
Chưa hợp phải nè, mọt thằng thằng thằng thằng bóng kết ước mơ,
nào vì có từ nhỏ,
đi ra gặng cháy mỏ hợt.
Mày bỏ hợt vào,
với trả nhiệm này.
Quảnh giờ anh quốc việc thực hiện,
với khoảng 5 tháng để khoảng 10 hình bụng lái này.
Mình đi ra loại,
nằm hai thông 2 bài,
nhiều hòng để cho 1 bí cóm,
đẹg,
hòng chưa chừng có loại nhiều vị trí ra,
nằm mình tầm,
nếu như cái vị trọt mũn,
giữ lửa đầm mẹ,
tầm nằm mình mở ra,
1 lán 1 phòng,
mấy bây bớst mà hành bụi lái,
1 phòng là mình tự làm,
1 phòng 1 phòng 1 bình tình hiểu thêm,
t оng ngồi trên đzym này.
Cỏng lên nhiều còng rấtping này.
H fun bạn nhiều
hư rả phải tháo rea advancing hoang hóa,
ra cái mới,
cái bản giải là một empire nó khi lập lại
thế pandemia.
Sau khız hợp lại nó đ regionalع hôm này.
Nó phải từ nào mà h heaven bụng đường.
Fale là Mó ngồi ngôi chom.
G 비슷 đường từ cạ muôn này.
Mới lực tr EC,
giáo hiểu nhé,
nhé thì đường mới làm phúc đến mục tiến,
tất to thập dành gít,
bán khức giả tempo với gässed đến mục bán rổi vüy thế.